it's not just san francisco or this is
happening by the way jason rants our
west coast correspondent's been looking
into this he's a radio show host in
seattle of course he joins us tonight
hey jason
hey i would argue that disaster is
probably an understatement so the
department of homelessness and
supportive housing they poured 160
million dollars into a program to create
these homeless hotels they turn hotel
rooms into permanent supportive housing
that ends up getting managed by various
non-profits and it's been a total
failure at least 166
fatal drug overdoses between 2020 and
2021 at these hotels the homeless have
been violent there we're talking about
assaults stabbing fires threats to kill
staff on top of that some of the hotels
are in total shambles bathrooms and
elevators don't work serious rat
infestations roaches are everywhere one
homeless woman said she pitched a tent
inside of her room to keep the rats or
the bugs out
the goal for these hotels is to get
homeless people into independent housing
but the city tracked over 500 people who
actually left the program they found a
quarter of them died 21 return to
homelessness 27 percent left the area
and couldn't be tracked at all only
about a quarter of them got into housing
again and those were mostly people
living with family or going into other
subsidized housing programs now thanks
to mayor london breed who lobbied
against an oversight commission the
problems have only gotten worse
since the city created the department of
homelessness
homelessness increased by 56 percent
this according to the chronicle now
despite that earlier this month we got
an announcement from mayor breed that
she's purchasing another hotel
and as you point out different versions
basically of the strategy are happening
all across the country so last month in
los angeles homeless people at an
encampment were moved to a four-star
hotel as part of a county and city
program here in seattle they're spending
tens of millions of dollars in king
county to buy hotels for low barrier
permanent housing the most recent one is
just feet away from a school and then
new york they pushed 100 million dollars
into this hotel conversion program it's
been stalled because of zoning laws so
the democrats are basically saying okay
let's push a bill to make it easier to
create these homeless hotels
they are failing everywhere they go and
it's not just local dollars to your
point the biden administration is
putting a lot of dollars into it through
covet funds
it's also cruel i mean it just results
in people dying jason rants
as always such a detailed and precise
accounting appreciate it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight